si dans quelques jours de nombreux
établissements de loisirs vont pouvoir
ouvrir leurs portes et accueillir à
nouveau des clients certains
s'inquiètent plus que d'autres de la
façon dont les contraintes sanitaires
vont impacter leur activité c'est le cas
par exemple de france aux ateliers le
gérant d'un club naturiste de près de
monflanquin car si ses clients choisie
sur l'établissement c'est bel et bien
pour vivre en toute liberté et pouvoir
se promener sans contraintes
vestimentaires une mentalité 100% anti
textile qui interroge sera-t-il possible
de faire porter un masque à ses clients
qui refusent de porter un slip pour ce
gérant si la question est légitime il
reste assez optimiste oui l'image peut
paraître un peu surprenante pour un
naturiste de porter un masque mais les
règles seront les mêmes pour tout le
monde
autre problème de taille pour ce gérant
si la france est une terre d'accueil
pour les naturistes du monde entier la
fermeture des frontières inquiète pour
lui sans touristes étrangers il sera
difficile de faire le plein nous avons
plus de 50% de nos clients qui viennent
des pays étrangers notamment des pays
bas on attend toujours des informations
quant à la réouverture des frontières
mais on sait déjà qu'ils seront nombreux
à ne pas venir cet été chez françois les
naturistes ne seront sûrement pas très
nombreux mais ils l'assurent pour ceux
qui auront tout de même décidé de ne pas
déroger à leurs habitudes et de se
reconnecter avec leur corps et la nature
il sera possible de respecter les gestes
barrières tout en se promenant
entièrement nu et voilà alors on vous
donne des infos et moi j'ai peut-être
trouvé la solution
je me dis pour ces personnes qui veulent
pas porter de marche j'ai peut-être la
solution pour eux regarder j'ai envoyé
des potes au camping camping naturiste
voilà merci j'ai quelques lourdeurs non
mais c'est vrai que normalement on
rappelle jean michel maire
la règle des naturistes et ils refusent
tout textile tout textile textile
exactement il s'est laissé le refus
d'avoir le moindre le moindre barrière
entre l'autre et soi donc c'est cissé
d'une haute estime et d'autres textes
donc les basques c'est de trop
mais d'après lui et non pas ils vont pas
nous casser les noisettes et pauline ont
passé le dernier souci c'est bien de
savoir la nature et ceux qui vont partir
en retrait on respecte tout le monde
mais il ya d'autres soucis leurs
histoires de ma nature écoutez-moi
police incurie ce bon je suis bizarre
naturiste oui vraiment ça va fais toi
plaisir un rené invasives ont un coût un
papier peint la chloroquine barre est
très bien merci d'excuser moyer
c'est un m c'est un pote à nous on ne
connaît pas très bien